now look at this garbled this what a
disaster I've headed from this into one
of these okay that's where I'm going so
you can see that for any of these the
only way to get to one of these is to do
some completion of the swear but I need
to do some factorization now immediately
I can rule out see how I've got four one
two three four I can rule that one and
three can you see why without doing any
work I can rule out what I'm bring my
yeah I have a I have an expert hanging
out here and I'm going to why bit
hanging out here right now you can see
this has no single excerpt or whiter
notice this right nothing else is being
squared that's why you're going to get
that bit that's why I know I had some
horizontal or vertical shift in play so
I need to find out what it is ok so to
make things easy let me show you the way
that I always factorizing this in my
first line ok don't panic I'm gonna do
three things I'll tell you the three
things and then we'll do them the first
thing is I want to group my ex's
together in my wires together but do
that the second thing is once I group
them I'm going to factorize it as well
because I want to get to this right and
thirdly I'm going to kick this constant
which really belongs on the right hand
side i'm going to kick it over the other
side ok it sounds like a lot but I
promise you it's not that hard how old
firstly let's start with it so i see i
have 4x squared and 24 x you happy with
that so therefore I'm going to take out
a common factor 4x squared 24x but I
take out what nothing do I take out the
answer support yeah good you're pretty
much always going to take out the
coefficient of x square because you're
going to land here I don't want any
numbers hanging out in there right there
all the coefficients come out when you
factorize so I'll take my floor out
which leaves me with that really good
and then I do the same for the wise ok
so what can I take out of the wiser but
9y squared and minus 36 wine gonna take
our knife
how does that look have I group drop my
X's and Y's they look good and of course
that constant which is 36 he doesn't
belong over there i'm left with the
other guys sorry Austin he belongs on
the right-hand side he's going to tend
to one eventually all right having done
this I'm now set up to complete the
square in fact I'm gonna complete two
squares right so here what do I have to
add inside these brackets to look like I
square the answer is nine but don't
forget I'm not really adding not am I I
am in fact a DS 36 very good so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to write that
plus 36 right away before I forget that
I've done that I've had a 36 in there
now I want to complete this square what
do I need to advocate oh yeah the answer
is I had plus 4 but of course we know
it's not really for by coincidence it is
also 36 so i had to lots of 36 and said
hey you see what I've done all right
having completed this way I'm ready to
factorize because these aren't our
squares right so I have got X plus 3 or
squared + y minus my minus one minute
mms 2 elsewhere once I resolve all the
clusters act like I terms on the
right-hand side I have the negative 36
in the 30 who cancels so you just end up
with those six okay I'm always there I'm
almost out one of these forms only need
to do one more thing I've got to /
whatever will give me one on my hand
side which is 36 ok so once i do that i
am at my fall
correct okay so that's all that lucky
around the Institute to the equation now
we need to drill some conclusion okay so
first thing the easiest thing to read
off is just the center it's sitting
right there that was the whole point of
all that factorizing work what is the
center of the lips on a negative 3 comma
2 that wasn't so hot okay now this next
thing I don't need right away but I
might as well stated I have my a squared
in my b squared sitting right there okay
so might as well use this to work out a
and B they will be handy later when i'm
doing like these steps over here and try
to work out where the focuses okay so
there's the center a and B I just read
off from the bigger the smaller number
you take the square root and that gives
you what's a 3 and b is 2 done thank you
be good now have a look at what we're
asked to find Center focal director sees
I found the center to get the fur kind
of director sees I've got a and B what's
that last piece that I need I need the
eccentricity right a B&E there
everything so once you've got something
to want the portlet
I can determine the eccentricity just by
algebra right so in fact I like to write
the fact that I am doing that I say
determine eccentricity because as you've
already noticed there is a lot of there
are a lot of equations fly around ok and
now i'm going to go straight to that
relationship we determine B squared
equals that now B squared + B squared I
already know what they are they are for
a nice right okay you can see in this
step is this series of steps is always
going to be the same i'm going to divide
through for online and then I switch
they do that switcheroo so i'm going to
subtract each i'm going to add any
squared to both sides and i'm going to
subtract for online for both sides okay
so that lands us with a square on the
left and what do I have on the run five
unknown right one last step before I get
me which is just to take the square root
and at this point it's not like a
hundred percent necessary but we should
say I have excluded an answer right
because there are two solutions to this
equation I'm going to take it this one
why have I done that it's a ratio right
so therefore i could say e is greater
than zero kind of my definition of what
the eccentricities so there we go so
that was almost all the hard work now
I'm just trying to put them in an age of
it being a substitution right so let's
see the photograph first now if you have
another color here this will be useful
to work out which of these we're going
to use last fall right I've already
eliminated two because I better centers
lot of the origin but which one of these
do I use how do i tell which one of
these is in operation what was the
difference between these experience
which way if I stretch which way is the
major actors and I can tell about and
this is the way that I do it like you
can write in a different way if you like
but i find this quite reliable I look at
these numbers right and I say look this
is bigger so I say major axis right I in
fact I right major there and I right
next to the X so that tells me I'm
stretching this way okay and then I'm
not the minor axis over here okay so
this is my metal tag to distinguish now
I know when I'm working out there I like
to do it in this order because now I'm
ok now I'm traveling a long as major
answers right I've got this way here
video on the x-axis right wrong color so
i can say the foci are at where's the
center h that's minus 3 plus or minus
any ear there's a and there's e so
what's a bee it's just the script come
on and I've also had vertical shift it's
two units so there you go there's the
[ __ ] up doing the direct receipt in a
similar way I know they've also gone
this way also gone that way so boom
excuse me they're also going to start
with that H number so X is going to be
negative 3 plus or minus ok I do I like
to write this step up because I could
confuse I'm going to get fractions on
fractions in a second a or a there's a
on e busy this is root 5 on 30 you saw
how i did the foci i just did them all
in one hit ok because you are doing ayee
cuz you're doing AE you're almost always
we talked about this before you're
always get some cancellation happening
this gets to be nice and neat this
number and this number tend to match up
right but here it's the opposite I find
when I do just from practice I find when
I do this in my head then where did the
foci I always thought invent like fifty
percent i get a role because i do this
fraction a fraction thing incorrectly so
being that you can see it there what
happens that three other denominator
over the denominator hold it multiplies
the numerator right some practice is 9
on fun now I could uh I could
rationalize this and write it as nine to
five on five but mostly you'll find it's
not that big a deal because I'm not
going to be adding this fraction to
anything else and there's no like
there's no common fantasy there's no
advantage to simplifying it
rationalizing that work all right so let
me just rewind we did a lot of things
okay so let me just put some tags on
them ok first we started and we went
through all of this it looks like a lot
of algebraic work what what heading and
you put over all this what we try to do
we're trying to complete the square and
really factorize that's where I'm
landing okay so this whole step is the
factorization step you step one factor I
take
okay step two we looked at these
features step 2 these features are the
ones you just read straight off the
equation right I don't need any move in
your pleasure anymore in fact the
factorization what is the manipulation I
did the Centaur a and B they're just
sitting there all of the equation just
read them all okay see so I factorize
personally secondly I rid of the easy
features okay um thirdly what do i do
thur these where do I go from there yeah
went to eccentricity greater number
three is eccentricity the way you can
room that is if you get to know you've
got a and B and you're like what do I do
with a and B heads up use them to get in
last step number four remember how I
call these the easy features right it's
a kind of a harder features they took a
little more arm a little more hand like
sort of manipulation to get to them not
a lot more but a little bit more and
it's important when you do step for that
you identify what the major axis is
because that'll tell you do you might
feel quite good this way or do they go
in that way that's a really common error
to make students kind of get this in
their hair it's the more common one and
so they don't even think to worry about
or which ones major out which one's mine
up they just go straight into a feel and
that's where they surrendered okay